Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Vous l'aimez comment vous, votre café ?
Long, court, allongé, ristretto ?
Avec ou sans sucre ?
Après l'eau,
c'est la boisson la plus consommée dans le monde.
90% des Français confessent qu'ils en raffolent.
Boire du café est-il vraiment bon pour la santé ?
Est-ce que ça empêche vraiment de dormir
comme on le dit ?
Allez, je vous raconte tout et, promis, ça sera sans filtre !
Un chiffre pour commencer :
2,6 milliards.
C'est le nombre de tasses de café
qui sont bues chaque jour à travers le monde.
Deux habitants sur trois en consomment sur la planète
sous différentes formes : café turc, expresso, café filtre...
Ce qui en fait la marchandise la plus exportée,
juste derrière le pétrole.
Pas étonnant qu'on le qualifie de nouvel or noir.
Les Français en raffolent.
Et pourtant, nous sommes loin d'être les plus gros buveurs de café dans le monde.
Ce sont les Finlandais qui caracolent en tête avec
7,4 kg de café par an et par personne.
En deuxième et troisième positions,
on trouve les Néerlandais et les Suédois,
qui consomment environ 7 kg de café par an et par personne.
Avant de vous dire si le café empêche ou non de dormir,
il faut d'abord que je vous raconte
l'incroyable épopée de cette boisson.
On produit du café dans 90 pays,
beaucoup en Amérique centrale et en Amérique du Sud.
Et pourtant, le café n'est pas originaire de cette région du monde.
Il vient même d'un autre continent : d'Afrique.
On dit qu'un berger éthiopien aurait découvert le café par hasard, grâce à ses chèvres.
Alors qu'il promenait son troupeau,
il aurait constaté que ses bêtes s'agitaient et dansaient
après avoir mangé les fruits du caféier.
C'est une légende.
Toutefois, c'est bien en Éthiopie que l'idée de consommer
la graine de café
aurait germé. Les toutes premières
traces écrites concernant le café datent du IXᵉ siècle.
On y fait allusion à ses effets vivifiants
et son rôle facilitant la digestion.
Des fouilles récentes laissent supposer qu'à la préhistoire,
le café faisait déjà partie de l'alimentation
des habitants de cette région.
Ce sont les Arabes qui, à partir du XVᵉ siècle,
vont développer la culture du caféier à travers tout
le Proche-Orient et la péninsule arabique.
Ils ont aussi l'idée de torréfier les grains.
Là-bas, on l'appelle "kawa", un mot yéménite qui signifie "revigorant".
Au fil des ans et des voyages, le mot se transforme.
Il devient "kahve" en Turquie, "Kai-fey" en Chine.
Au Danemark, c'est "Kaffe" avec un K,
en italien "caffè" et "coffee" en anglais.
Un mot aux consonances identiques d'une langue à l'autre.
En Europe, il faut attendre le XVIIᵉ siècle
pour que le café fasse son apparition sur les tables.
- Et pour cause, les Arabes veillent au grain.
- C'est ça !
Ils vont quand même pas tuer la poule aux œufs d'or.
Ils interdisent les exportations de plants et même de graines.
Ils ne vendent aux Européens
que des grains gris,
autrement dit des grains ébouillantés ou de vieux grains
pas assez frais pour germer et donner des arbustes.
Mais en 1616, des marchands hollandais
parviennent à leur dérober quelques plants de café.
Et comme le caféier a besoin de chaleur et d'humidité,
c'est dans leur colonie en Indonésie qu'ils vont le planter.
Devant le succès de l'opération,
les Anglais font la même chose.
Et voilà comment des caféiers atterrissent en Inde,
une colonie britannique.
À ce stade de l'histoire, il n'y a toujours pas de café
sur le continent américain, mais il approche.
En 1714, la ville d'Amsterdam offre un plant de caféier à Louis XIV.
Le souverain français apprécie cette boisson.
Le caféier est planté sous serre, il fructifie,
mais pour produire les fameux grains,
il faut un climat plus adapté que celui de la métropole.
Alors, comme l'ont fait les voisins,
la France transfère de jeunes pousses de caféiers sous les tropiques,
dans ses colonies, vers la Martinique d'abord,
puis la Guadeloupe, Saint-Domingue et la Guyane.
Et ça marche. Le café devient une boisson à la mode
à la Cour et dans Paris, des maisons du café s'ouvrent dans la capitale,
dont le fameux Procope, qui existe toujours.
Grâce à ces plantations, la France deviendra même un temps
le premier producteur de café du monde.
Les Espagnols et les Portugais, installés en Amérique centrale et en Amérique du Sud,
non loin des Antilles donc,
comprennent alors les bénéfices
qu'ils pourraient eux aussi tirer de la production du café.
Personne ne voulant leur en céder, ils décident donc
de voler des caféiers aux Français et les plantent dans leurs colonies.
La plante trouve des conditions idéales
et sa culture s'étend sur un immense territoire.
Au fil des siècles, elle va devenir l'une des cultures emblématiques
de toute cette région du monde.
Aujourd'hui, 90 pays produisent au total
10000 tonnes de café par an.
La plus grande partie en Amérique du Sud et en Amérique centrale,
le Brésil arrivant sur la première marche du podium
avec 30% de la production mondiale.
Selon la plupart des experts,
le meilleur café du monde serait produit sur l'île de La Réunion
en France donc, dans l'océan Indien.
Il porte un très joli nom : le Bourbon pointu.
Bourbon pour l'île Bourbon,
ancien nom de l'île de La Réunion,
pointu à cause de la forme de son fruit.
Regardez ces belles cerises, ça donne envie, hein ?
Et pourtant, elles n'ont pas vocation à être consommées.
Enfin, pas sous cette forme. Ce sont les cerises du caféier.
Cet arbuste tropical peut faire jusqu'à cinq mètres de hauteur.
Ces cerises charnues sont pourvues d'un noyau qui est divisé en deux parties : les fameux grains de café.
L'obtention des grains est une opération assez complexe.
Il faut d'abord retirer la peau, la pulpe
et ensuite l'enveloppe qui recouvre les grains,
ce qu'on appelle la parche.
Il n'y a qu'un endroit dans le monde où il n'y a rien à faire.
En Thaïlande, les grains sont récoltés
directement dans des crottes d'éléphant.
Le pachyderme se nourrit des branches de caféier,
mais il ne digère pas le noyau des cerises.
- Beurk ! Mais c'est dégoûtant.
- Il faut croire que non.
Ça donne un café très goûteux
dont, paraît-il, on se souvient pendant longtemps.
Peut-être aussi à cause de son prix :
jusqu'à 2300€ le kilogramme.
Une fois extraits, les grains de café n'ont aucune odeur.
Les arômes sont piégés à l'intérieur. Pour les libérer,
le café doit être torréfié, c'est-à-dire chauffé et grillé.
La palette aromatique du café est très importante,
plus importante que celle du vin.
On compte jusqu'à 800 arômes différents,
contre 5 à 600 pour le vin.
Cette fois, il ne reste plus qu'à le moudre.
Et j'en viens à la question du départ :
le café nous tient-il éveillés ?
Le mot est peut être un peu fort, mais ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'après avoir avalé un café, on ressent comme un coup de fouet.
On est prêt à démarrer de nouveau au quart de tour.
C'est à cause de la caféine.
Identifiée pour la première fois dans le café,
cette molécule est présente
dans une soixantaine de plantes,
le thé, le maté et même le chocolat.
Cette molécule a pour effet de stimuler le système nerveux.
C'est pour cette raison que notre rythme cardiaque accélère
parfois après avoir consommé du café.
Elle freine également l'accumulation d'adénosine dans le cerveau.
Il s'agit d'une molécule chargée de signaler
l'état de fatigue à l'organisme.
C'est pourquoi nous avons le sentiment que le café nous réveille ou nous empêche de dormir.
C'est donc ça ?
Pour faire la sieste, mieux vaut prendre un long.
Eh bien non !
S'ils sont plus forts en goût,
les expressos ne sont pas les plus riches en caféine.
La dose de caféine dépend du temps de contact
entre la mouture, c'est-à-dire le café moulu, et l'eau.
Or, plus le café est allongé, plus ce contact avec l'eau est long.
Par ailleurs, la caféine n'agit pas tout de suite.
Il faut attendre environ 30 minutes.
Ensuite, il faut entre 4 à 6 heures
pour que l'organisme en élimine 50%.
10 à 12 heures après l'ingestion,
il peut donc en rester jusqu'à 25%.
Résultat : si vous buvez un petit café sur les coups de 17h
eh bien à 23h, il vous restera environ 25 milligrammes de caféine dans le sang.
Vous risquez donc d'avoir un peu de mal à vous endormir.
Du coup, pour éviter les insomnies,
il est conseillé d'arrêter de boire du café
6 h au moins avant d'aller vous coucher.
Plus tôt, c'est encore mieux.
L'Agence européenne pour la sécurité des médicaments
recommande aux adultes de ne pas dépasser
400 milligrammes de caféine par jour,
soit l'équivalent de trois cafés filtre ou quatre expressos.
Si vous respectez ces recommandations,
le café ne devrait pas vous empêcher de dormir.
Mieux, il vous fera du bien,
car le café a des vertus que
vous ne soupçonnez peut-être pas.
La caféine a notamment une action vasoconstrictrice.
Autrement dit, elle favorise la contraction des vaisseaux sanguins.
La caféine permet de diminuer l'inflammation des vaisseaux.
Voilà pourquoi un café peut parfois soulager une migraine.
Des études récentes
ont aussi montré que boire 3 à 4 tasses de café par jour
réduirait le risque d'infarctus du myocarde de 12%
et le risque d'AVC de 8 à 13%.
Plus surprenant encore, 3 à 5 tasses de café par jour
diminueraient le risque de développer un diabète de type II.
Mais là, il ne s'agit que d'hypothèses.
Du coup,
je vais reprendre une petite tasse de café, moi.
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
et qu'elle vous a donné envie de partager un bon café entre amis.
En attendant, n'hésitez pas à liker et à nous suggérer
d'autres idées en commentaires. À très bientôt !